[Music]
kelly gave me these
this article here
here's what it said abc action news
because all news is action
just got out of a relationship had a bad
day at work or are you stressed and need
to release without hurting yourself
someone else or damaging your property
so
are you a grown-up who is in desperate
need of a childhood temper tantrum to
kick your little feet and to cuddle up
with your blankie and to be met
some therapist
good geniuses thanks for that maybe you
should have read one or two textbooks in
grad school are recommending a rage room
or a smash room
a temper tantrum room
a
pee in my pants and poo poo in my diaper
room
starting to pop up across the country
i won't even read the names it's a
release a different form of expression
anytime somebody says
it's a form of expression hemorrhoids i
get instant hemorrhoids i go straight to
the preparation age isle it's just a
form of expression
oh gosh people coming in nurses teachers
they do it for a quick 15 minutes sit
down and relax afterwards and they go on
with their day
so many different aspects of how great
spending 15 to 20 minutes in a rage room
can help you feel and when it comes to
kit oh good let's bring our kids along
this will be fun thanks thanks parents
thanks adults
when it comes to kids it can be a fun
and safe activity
kids love it we have at least two
birthdays a week here
but kids aren't allowed to use glass or
heavy duty tools like sledgehammers only
adults throwing temper tantrums can do
that here's the thing
that
ah this gets me so frustrated
listen
your body doesn't work that way
what behaviors you choose
on the heels of feelings what behaviors
you choose on the heels of an emotion
encodes itself into your body and
becomes your default response
it's called neuroscience and i'm not
even a neuroscientist i'm a podcaster
and i know this
okay
what you do afterwards when you get
angry when you get frustrated when you
get sad when you get um
um
when you have a boo-boo in your diaper
and you're a grown whatever
what you choose to do next becomes your
default mechanisms your body outsources
it to automated response
so if you get angry
or tired and you go pay somebody money
to smash something with a hammer
to
to
crush glass to do tough things
your body will begin to automate an
angry violent response to those things
it's just the way our bodies work right
this idea it's this old pressure cooker
model it's not real it's not real that i
just have to quote unquote get my anger
out no
you don't
when your fight or flight when your
stress hormones kick up when your stress
chemicals if you will pulse through your
body like adrenaline cortisol those
things
channeling them towards rage channeling
them towards that's not what rage is but
channeling them towards anger towards
frustration towards you
just makes it that much easier for your
body to default there the next time and
the time after that and the time after
that and the time after that and by the
way you teach your kids that and they
grow up defaulting to that defaulting to
that defaulting to that
don't
stop
when you get frustrated
feel it
sit in it for a minute
say the words out loud with ah
sigh i'm frustrated i'm real frustrated
right now when you get angry all anger
is is a is a
physiological response pointing you
towards something you care about
i'm really pissed off i'm really angry
right now
because she's not supposed to treat him
that way
because my teacher is supposed to my
son's teacher is supposed to care a
little bit more about him
because the guy i hired with money i
don't really have to mow the lawn did a
crappy j that guy cut me off in traffic
and i'm not about to die
on the heels of a little square kia
who's driving like a maniac because
they're texting
say the things out loud and let your
body feel them
go for a walk
go for a run
let that be your default mechanism
grab a pen and a paper and write them
down i am really angry because
get in your car and sing 80s metal tunes
as loud as you can or whatever
nonsensical pop tunes on i don't know
what's in your head
train your body
to respond in productive ways in healthy
ways
and in
neuropsychologically com compatible ways
with overall well-being and health
rage rooms
listen i had a buddy growing up and we
would get stuff and smash it that's a
blast if we want to have smash rooms i'm
all for it like we can be mario brothers
but by calling them rage rooms but i
think we're solving things what we're
doing is we're just
tightening up the trigger towards an
angry response towards a response we're
not going to be able to get back towards
saying the thing screaming our lungs out
to throwing a temper tantrum stop
we are too stressed too fried too
exhausted too burnt out as a culture to
create
these pathological responses as quote
unquote solutions they're not they're
not
a walk is
a long long journal entry is how tough
is that
you can have a journal room
that'd be the lamest business ever come
to my journal room and write down your
whatever do something positive hey
here's a crazy idea call somebody that
you care about and say hey i don't need
your solutions i don't need your advice
i just need to vent for a minute i'm
going to talk to you because i trust you
here we go do that
and then when you get angry when you get
frustrated and you get sad and you get
overwhelmed your body will begin to look
for people to reach out to
and other people are one of the
cornerstones of psychological well-being
control autonomy is one of the core
functions of psychological well-being
not smashing everything and yelling and
scream
so there we go america that's we need
temper tantrum rooms